hello and welcome to the 2014 us chess
championship and u.s women's chess
championship
here in beautiful saint louis the
capital of towson america
we're in the central west end right
across the street from the world chess
hall of fame there's going to be a big
event there tomorrow
we're at the st louis chess club we've
had these events the u.s championship in
the u.s women's
for six years renee and we are past the
midpoint of this tournament and things
are really heating up
we've got our defending champion gotta
kamsky facing off against one of the
leaders and
we see the players arriving we see josh
riddell coming off
a win in the tournament he was pretty
thrilled about that our young star
is swara and she's getting set up no
doubt the uh the bow is obstructed only
by my view
and the always colorful tateva bahamian
and i'm jennifer shahady and i'm here
with grandmasters yasser sarwan
and maurice ashley and we'll be bringing
you all the action for
round six of the us women's and round
seven of the u.s championship
let's see the men tied at the top of
this competition not what you would
expect
alexander lenderman and varusian of
caliban both with four points after six
rounds
right behind them the two most
experienced
players in the field godakamsky
defending champion
and alexander ornisha super solid but
also lethal
the women's height at the top not as
much of a surprise
we've got irina crush the only
grandmaster in the field and ana
zatonski
four-time champion
and behind the women and behind the
leaders and the women we've got
tatev abrahamian a dangerous player
she's already played the tons game crush
and might be able to string together
some wins here as well
but really some big matchups today and
we've got maurice ashley for more on
that
indeed now that we've crossed the
halfway point the players can
begin to think about the finish line but
they have some powerful matchups today
they have to face off against certainly
the top board to look at
is kamsky versus lenderman lindemann
has never defeated komski at least not
what we've seen
in our database to date kamsky and
linderman
have fought quite a bit but komski has
won
at least four times that we've seen at
least in serious
competition so lindeman has his hands
full against godakomski today on the
woman's side
it's got to be a tale of the horse race
between
crush and zatonski they are both tied
right now they have
key matchups in rounds six and seven
before the critical matchup
in round eight when they face off
against each other
a game that will probably decide the
ladies championship
so big matchups today players getting
themselves
in line for a stretch run at these
championships
back to you jenny
well let's see are we getting news yet
not quite but you know one game that i'm
really excited about
is robson playing with the white pieces
against marija nakobian because
the last time these two battled into the
championship in that opening
robson won a nice game with white in the
pan up bought bennett
exactly some great match-ups
kobe and obviously tied for first uh
playing blackwood against ray that'll be
a big challenge
we've already mentioned godakamski's
he's playing also a co-leader alex
lenderman
but another game i really liking i'm
going to keep a close eye on
is timor garriev versus alex onishak we
keep repeating how tough it is to beat
ownership
and team morgaria having
had a very up and down tournament to
date really needs to
have a victory here to get him back into
contention
for the final rounds so i'm looking for
timor
to bring his a game and do something
very enterprising a little bit special
and offbeat
as we've seen in his play only short is
just going to look for the balance
try to neutralize the opening advantage
that white has
but that will be a great fight i'm
looking forward to
quite a number of battles in today's
round that's right i'm interested to
find out whether
okobian will play the french or the caro
khan
he seems to switch off between those
defenses what do you think he's going to
do against rey
he played the the cavalcon against rey
in 2012.
in 2013 in the chicago open he played
the french
and in the world open recently he won a
game where he also played the carol khan
but this time
instead of the pan of botfinec ray
played the advanced variation
and ocopian got the better of him in
that game so
do you think that because it was the
most recent game in the world open
the biggest open tournament in the
country um maybe this year the
millionaire will surpass it but world
open
usually in philadelphia it's been in dc
the last couple years
right um and so that's a major
tournament with big prize fund
um and i wonder if virginia will try to
remind ray of bad memories or do you
think he'll go with his
you know french which he's loved for
even longer right when
when you have two really excellent
defenses that you rely upon like the
caro and the french
basically it's a kind of a coin toss
and like you say you're trying to steer
your opponent into positions
that's going to make him most
uncomfortable just like you say just
because of the recent experience i would
probably have a bias
expectation that var would go for a car
con so your money's on the cara well but
not by much i mean it's
against
i'm losing all my sushi um
i would say it's uh about 51
51 wow don't go out on a limb though i
know
i know but what would really be very
very surprising
is if var um and his uh second
gabriel sarg sargassian prepared
something extra special
and yeah and even money that because
it could be more like a berlin 49
one right right gotta keep
gotta keep in mind your ass where yeah
there you go
and sometimes it's hustler i think
that's a good uh book title
subconscious hustler okay cool
we got some poker faces uh already
speaking of hustling
lenderman kamsky i think uh actually our
international arbiter carol jurecki is
going around asking the players
tomorrow's a free day
and today we have a special outing it's
really nice st louis chess club always
likes to do
special things for the players here and
tonight there's a cardinals game
right so the players um you know they
get to go to a box and eat
nachos all sorts of delicious food and
socialize and talk about the game while
enjoying
well i'm not going to say the cardinals
are the baseball capital
of the united states but certainly one
of the
one of the greatest fan bases of support
here in st louis and the cards
this is a baseball town well apparently
i'm dressed for the occasion
you certainly are red very good
awesome philadelphia very much so
i'm thinking more what god of camps he's
going to play now god has had a very
very slow
event he is at plus one a victory today
bang he he would become a co-leader he's
been
quiet almost like resigned in a certain
fashion
he spoke very pessimistically about his
chances of repeating as champion
so today is absolutely crucial if he can
win the game today
against the co-leader they'll switch
places
now god has got a problem he likes
closed positional maneuvering
but he's white and he really needs
to get an advantage against lenderman
with
only the exception of yesterday's game
alex lenderman
has been is his uh preparation
opening preparation has been spot on so
here i'm actually expecting
uh gada to play e2e4
and to really press with the white
pieces as hard as he can because he
knows
he's got a win today to climb back into
the race
i love that prediction so you go from 51
percent
into this very bold prediction of a one
e4 i
i would love to see gotta do that and i
think maurice has some thoughts on uh
that prediction indeed pretty dramatic i
think that
you're probably right yes he wants to go
into a sharper line
to really test lenderman the last time
they played in these championships
got a one on his way to winning the
title and i want to show you a position
where he played a beautiful move on move
42 this was the position he had
with the black pieces and he played the
move knight to g3
attacking the bishop on f1 of course
with the knight
and the rook and it was impossible to
defend the bishop and also impossible
to take the knight because of simply
rook takes
on f on f1 and then king up and
mate so he won a piece after knight to
g3
lindemann tried to struggle with rook to
g8 taking this back
uh taking this pawn but after knight
takes f1 king g2
knight to d2 got it was an entire piece
up
and lenderman had to resign not wanting
to
test the technique of the current
u.s champion they have begun and it
looks like
you would have won that bet if you had
taken it
jen he has started with a ready system
as quiet
cool quiet as possible possibly
realizing that lindeman's preparation
has been so majestic this tournament
that he doesn't want to test him in any
of the main lines
back to you guys slight disappointment
for me because i thought that
ghada would want to really come out of
the starting
box you know with a kind of a sprint
like mentality but
it is his style his uh python-like style
of just maneuvering and
bringing his pieces into excellent
positions so
the ready system is a good choice i'll
just
were you wrong you couldn't be more
wrong i couldn't be more wrong
also we also couldn't be more wrong
about robs and a covan
because because robson played one to d4
wow that's what i'm trying to do exactly
i mean
rob sander playing e4 in most of his
game does that look like
does that look like a dark square to you
it does it looks like d4 to me
d2 d4 the white pawn on d4 square
but this is interesting that he's
challenging
var in the queen pond
var is very solid in his queen's gambit
declines
positions so we remember the game
against garyv where he made a fool of
himself in the opening
only to dig in and eventually even win
that game
uh so to think that he cannot play
uh varusian in a queen pond
is a big surprise well this is just a
big surprise in general
you know e4 just aggressive attacking
player ray rathan switching to d4
probably because he prefers to play
against sicilians he probably prefers
playing against c5 e5 and
somehow he thinks that these um frenches
and carol khans are more solid and he
has a little bit of trouble with them
remember
bobby fischer we've been showing his
puzzles and
he didn't like playing the french
against the french either no he never
really did
uh overcome that particular opening
problem his taste
yeah he distaste um jacobian
interestingly is taking his time on his
very first move because he's thinking to
himself
okay uh rey has played d4
for a reason i usually play a queen pawn
defense um where is rey
trying to hit me where where right and
can i trust him
he doesn't exactly and if i play e6 will
he play e4
right so if i play c6 will he play e4 so
i think it was pretty smart for
professional decision here for coping to
think about it maurice what do you make
of this
the biggest stage switching up from e4
to d4
well i'm impressed quite frankly that
ray robson has decided
to deviate from what he normally does
with e4 you could almost bet 90
of the time if not greater that he's
going to play the e4 move
these gentlemen have met 12 times
at least in serious competition that we
have in the database
they've been 12 times rey has had white
8 times
out of those 12. in all 8 games he's
played e4
in the last four games he's had white
that they've contested against each
other he's played e4
all four times he's defeated ocobian
twice
in those e4 lines so it's not easy to
say that
that he doesn't want to see a carrot con
or a french because he's actually
defeated okobian
two out of the last four times jacobian
defeated him though two of the last four
times
those being french's and caro khan so
they they have battled they're
completely familiar with each other
i think when the move d4 landed on the
board okobian was certainly surprised
to see this move but now he's just
saying well
my preparation for e4 d4 whatever it is
is sound
but he's got to have the element of
surprise against him at least at this
moment
in the championships in this position in
the game
back to you guys thank you maurice
i i couldn't agree with you more
and from mccobian's point of view he's
simply saying okay i'll play
my a my first defense the queen's gambit
declined and let's see what you've got
prepared
the game that i'm keeping my eyes out on
is the timor gari of
alex onishok game because i did expect
that t-more one would want to do
something a little bit different a
little bit
enterprising and we have a hybrid system
it's a nimzo indian defense knight c3
bishop b4
let me just take you through the opening
so you can see what i mean
all of these moves are very very common
at the elite level
knight c3 bishop before the bishop
obviously comes to pin the knight
against white's king my favorite
response
has been queen c2 the classical
there's the rubenstein variation
e2 e3 mainline variations with knight f3
and
this move g2 g3 often called
the romanian rumination variation to
nimzo
in honor of oleg romanesh and
grandmaster
from the ukraine that popular
popularized this move g2 g3 so much so
that in the 1985
world championship match the second
match that
was played between anatoly karpov and
gary kasparov
gary used this g3 variation to great
effect
and actually won that match and became
world champion with this system
so the idea behind g3 obviously
is not only to fianchetto the bishop
on the g2 square but simultaneously to
prevent
black from playing those uh queenside
fianchettos
uh queens indian type of positions with
b7 b6 but at the same time i mean a lot
of times in nimzo we play against the c4
pawn
well precisely it's not considered to be
one of the most testing lines against
the nimzo and yet
ownership already taking his time wasn't
expecting this
well i think like me he probably uh
felt that timor was going to
come with something a little bit offbeat
unusual we saw the hippopotamus that
sent us uh yesterday in a frenzy
discussion
but you're absolutely right one of the
things in the nimzo indian is this pawn
on c4
can become quite weak the most
aggressive or let's say
challenging uh moved to
uh the g2 g3 is c7 c5
and we could see for example this
variation and again
notice how this pawn on c4 kind of
stands out a little bit
here we've seen queen c7
and there are lines where white gambits
this pawn
another attractive and i like to do this
is black myself
another attractive option is once you've
in the move c7 c5 and knight f3 these
two moves are included
i like this counter-attacking move uh
knight
on f6 to e4 putting pressure against
this knight on c3
one of the reasons behind this move c7
c5
is you is you can swing your queen out
nicely
over here to a5 increasing the pressure
against the knight and there are a lot
of variations that go like
this that looks kind of fun for black
yeah yeah we should point out that a
pawn takes e3 queen takes c3
snags the rook on a1 you know this is
kind of a typical thing that happens in
the nimzo especially when white plays
some of the slower lines
like bishop g5 or g3 that you kind of
place that immediate pressure on c3 and
e4
exactly kind of what we saw between
lenderman and shanklin from yesterday
where um black got great counter play
and eventually created weak pawn on c3
sam won that weak pawn and then dragged
alex to his doom and caused him his
first defeat in the championships
but let's see in let me see what
alex actually decided on his defense
against g3
alex ownership that's right you know we
have two irenas and two alex's i know
so normally normally we have more than
two alex's i think this is kind of like
a
dearth of alex's right right usually
we've got what alex ivanov
perhaps alexander shabala of course alex
you're malinsky
alexander ivanov i mean we've got lots
of sashas
so usually we could be talking about six
people here it's either one ashok or
lenderman but hey they're leading the
tournament
right exactly so uh
onishook castled as black
okay perhaps the most flexible
continuation
and play d7 d5 okay
now we're kind of what white is going to
try to do
is to transpose into a lines of a
catalan where he can
argue either in his favor that the
bishop
on b4 is misplaced or black will try to
argue that the bishop
is well placed in a catalan knight f3
takes
a 2 a3 an invitation to upon sacrifice
by gariev if black
wanted to it's a it's a very very
challenging decision he could
take this uh knight on c3
and try for a variation like b7 b5
trying to maintain his pawn on c4 let me
just show you
one possibility in this case
black puts his knight on the d5 square
to
blunt the long diagonal and again
black is a pawn up in this variation but
the
line is very sharp uh
onishik wanted nothing to do with that
after a3 he simply retreated the bishop
and said your turn and let me see
we've got some really major opening
surprises here in the us championship uh
chime in at our hashtag u.s chess champs
and
don't forget that there are chess.com
prizes adults
with great questions will receive a free
diamond membership to test.com
we're giving out one a day and juniors
will receive a free gold membership to
chesskid.com now a lot of those prizes
we're giving out actually
here at the club on the weekends but
you're also eligible if you're
a kid at home you know you can also
email us
at comments at st louis chessclub.org
i actually tweeted yesterday using the
hashtag u.s chess champs but i came up
with another great hashtag
chessboard apps you know they say like
washboard ads but now it's chessboard
abs
because i was thinking of that men's
health article right right
chess makes you smart and how fit a lot
of the top chess players are including
magnus carlsen
who is kind of the the prototype for
chessboard abs perfect
respect nice it's all those push-ups you
know
right everybody thinks it's just about
the arms but you know that's getting
chessboard abs too by the way how's your
pull-ups can you do pull-ups it's always
been hard for women to pull up
but ask me next year ask me next year
why what you doing because i'm doing
crossfit
very good okay now i have a challenge
one year it's
yeah we'll see all right um
in the game between gariev and oni shook
ownership
did drop back with his bishop kind of
expected
i the the normal variation for white now
continues knight e5
what white wants to do is regain his
pawn on c4 and keep in mind this bishop
on g2
very very nice bishop it lies in ambush
on this long diagonal hey i actually got
one arrow right cool
and after c7 c5 a number of games have
gone into this
end game type of position or i should
just say
the queens get traded early usually that
it's not that exciting but
again what white is hoping for is that
after he wins his pawn
this pawn on c4 this bishop on c8 will
have a hard time
becoming an effective piece uh fighting
effective development so the
the jury's still out as to who's out fox
2
in this critical game
well we also have some great uh
questions coming in our hashtag u.s
chess champs one comment actually that
um timur looks great today in bright red
so do you fishing for a compliment
remember ferdell yesterday he wore a
black and white check
so right not the chess players are
superstitious
but we have a question actually about
chess in the schools in chess curriculum
with all the data showing the benefit of
teaching chess in the schools what are
the chances that the u.s will follow
countries like armenia and make chess a
part of the national required curriculum
ryanharps on chess.com what are the
chances
well ryan first of all thank you for the
softball question because that is
actually
what the mission of the st louis chess
club and scholastic center is all about
is bringing chess into the classroom a
lot of success
across the united states in using chess
as an
after-class activity with
a lot of resistance and in terms of
bringing it in
to the chess curriculum into the
curriculum as an
in-class activity okay so
you know it's an up uphill battle but
again the studies the empirical evidence
is so
obvious and compelling that we are
making
um inroads and as other countries
for example the european union
parliament thanks to initiative
launched by gary kasparov and silvio de
nilov
the eu parliament in 2012 passed a
proclamation
encouraging chess in the 28 nation eu
to bring chess into uh
classes so slowly slowly we're getting
there
and the initiative here in st louis
has been uh really spearheading that
recognition
nice answer yesterday i was just going
to say yes and 100 percent
oh very good you have a lot of detail
yes yes we got another question from
somebody who
clearly is inspired by my jacket and
wants to start fire because he asks
what increments are being used and do
you guys think they should be dropped i
think this guy's following maurice
ashley's facebook page
right 150 comments something like that
well maurice actually started a
firestorm
but in truth he's absolutely right
the increments great for the players it
makes it very easy upon them
it takes away all the drama disagree
with that
though okay although i do think 30
seconds is a little long i think that
sometimes the increment can increase the
drama this is also my brother's argument
because
people stay in time pressure for a
really long time kind of like a roller
coaster you go up you go down you go up
you go down rather than just like bam
you're out
but maurice do you think they should be
dropped this uh
softball question from craig harrison on
twitter
well i don't know craig you probably are
following me on facebook and you know
that i believe that increments
absolutely should be dropped in fact
right now as we speak i'm dropping them
from the millionaire chess open
because i didn't think about it
carefully enough when we first
put that out there so yes increments
don't make any sense to me
except for the players and the arbiters
most importantly yes your argument i
think
that you went back to the historical
reasons for the increment
and that i think is very compelling a
lot of players don't realize
that the increments really got
instituted because
of the arbiters they were tired of
trying to figure out
what happened at the end of time
controls and making sure that
players wrote down their moves and so
when they heard increments they were
like yeah this works for us
this works really well for us but the
players don't necessarily like
increments
some players do the ones who don't
manage their times their time very
well they love it because they get the
extra 30 seconds it's like great
hand me 30 seconds gift me as i'm in
time pressure save me from my
my own lack of time management skills
but it does it just doesn't make sense
matter of fact
the world championship was not played by
increments in the first two time control
the one between
carlson and anand it was so great why
didn't those two great players
decide that they really wanted it for
the the first two time controls they did
do it
after move 60 and the candidates that
were just recently played
again were not played with increments in
the first two time controls
so i think that there's nothing that the
players embrace like this is the
greatest thing
since sliced bread i believe that
increments
really take away from the drama and your
and your brother's argument to me
jen that they increase the drama keeping
people in pressure back and forth when
they're in when they're in time
trouble most players who
favor the increment do not like that
argument and they they don't think
that's any good they're like what do you
mean we're going to be in time pressure
and in and out of time pressure
constantly that is not why they argue
for they argue for
pure chess because that's what we all
play is
pure chess one thing's for sure we're
all in agreement we like to make the
game more exciting and uh we should keep
trying new things and
you know the u.s championship has been
doing a good job of that this format
we've had a lot of different formats we
tried to be very innovative here at the
st
louis uh club in terms of the format
flexible um bringing wild card players
for example
we're 24 players we had last year you
know this year is one of the more
traditional
formats absolutely the round robins are
the most traditional format
but luckily for the championship the
field is just like a lot tougher than it
has been in other years it's very tight
right so we're still seeing a lot of
excitement and honestly i'm not that
surprised
when i saw the list of players i didn't
think that it was going to be
um boring even though sometimes around
robin has that risk
i just thought that here there was going
to be a lot of one
one of these youngsters was going to
like start stringing wins together and
we'd have some fun
oh without question certainly that is
being realized on the board
so yeah thank you for uh your questions
guys and uh keep them coming
hashtag u.s chess champs well i'll steal
a little thunder
and i'll just say for those of you who
are intrigued by the debate by the time
we get to the poll ultimate round
between arena
and anna we're going to show some
historical
footage of what a real
time trouble and a time scramble can
look like
and if you don't think there was drama
in that game boy
you're not breathing oh that game was
pretty insane
that was in the 08 women's championship
uh irena crash and hassetonski
played a famous or infamous notorious
both
mostly infamous i think but yeah it's
got us
over 60 000 hits on youtube and counting
and this is a really a crazy finish that
actually ended up in anna zatonski
earning one of her first titles
right it's it's uh easy
to forget because anatomy is such a
fixture in the u.s women's chess team
but she hasn't
been playing for the u.s for that many
years i mean she actually had a totally
separate career
playing for ukraine and i think she won
three women's ukrainian championships
absolutely so pretty amazing career by
anna zatonski that
you know she still looks so young and
she's won
a combined total of ukrainian and u.s
women's championships
uh probably seven or eight right now
she's a very very
very successful career obviously um
just switching uh for a moment
i i'm also paying attention to
the game between sam shanklin sam as we
just
as we know just uh upended our
tournament leader in the previous round
he's playing against daniel nordicky
both players from the west coast daniel
uh as saying his usual kings indian
defense let's just quickly
go through that the moves of that
game
they're both familiar with one another
having played each other quite a number
of times i don't know what their
individual heads-up
match-up is like in this position the
main move in the king's indian defense
is knight c6
and certainly the move that daniel has
played most often
this capture pawn takes d4 that again
gary kasparov used to good effect
in his 1990 in his fifth and final match
against anatoly karpov in new york
and lyon was a big surprise at that time
knight takes rook e8 f3 knight c6 the
reason why
black usually doesn't voluntarily go in
for this line
is that the pawn formation of the pawns
on c4 and e4
in particular give black give white
pardon me
uh wonderful control over this very
key central d5 square and as we know in
the openings it's a big fight for
control of the center
so this line of play is genuine
generally considered
dangerous for black but daniel king came
to this game
with a very very specific idea in mind
another violation of our opening
principles he moves
a piece for the second time early in the
game
and he did it for a very concrete reason
and that
is he wants dan that is to say naradiski
wants to pl to take control over the f4
square
and if white's not careful black wants
to go
queen h4 followed by bishop takes h2
and a quick checkmate on
the king site so a very concrete problem
for sam shanklin to solve in
this position early and daniel looks
pretty confident and sam is thinking
yeah
and sam's thinking so also a key game
to keep a close eye on as
these two very promising talented
players of america's future
uh do battle oh by the way i just wanted
to say
the u.s women's championship sure i just
wanted to point out
one small detail here that the move g2
g4 trying to kick this knight away would
be
uh a dreadful move as it would
allow black a vicious attack
with his queen black's getting at least
a perpetual check out of this attack
so a move that you might want to
consider g2g4
is simply unplayable which ladies game
would you like me to go to
oh arena yeah let's start with our our
tournament leader co-leader irena crash
and she's playing against alyssa
malaquina
with the white pieces wow that game has
really
uh developed very quickly uh the players
have moved fast in the opening
arena queen pawn and
we get wow a blumenthal gambit
the blacks formation is known as a
benoni and the bononi defense
usually involves this sequence of moves
to get to the bononi
but black played b7
b5
a move that a defense that is really um
great for counter-attacking players if
you if you like to get an early
initiative with
black playing these types of gambits is
very very useful especially if your
opponent's not familiar with
the bloomfield game that the problem is
that arena is a really experienced
player and she's probably has a
variation
in mind in case of the blue moon fold
so here we see white has captured the
pawn
on d5 d5 b5 pardon me
uh what black has
compensation for the pawn has this
beautiful
classical pawn center duo so
clear compensation at the moment and
e2e4
by arena attacking black
in the center d5 d4
attacking the knight on c3 e4 e5
and things are really getting sharp in
this game early
black decided to move her knight back
notice that in this particular position
if you take the knight white is really
happy
with this queen trait first of all black
loses the right of castles
and secondly black's pawn structure is
really an ugly looking pawn structure
here so there's no reason for black to
voluntarily go into
this poor position no that doesn't give
much compensation
no it does not and furthermore if you
play the move
knight d5 well this knight on c3
could easily find a very nice home on
the e4 square so that's why we
understand the move
knight f6 to d7 leaving this bishop
on b7 the diagonal open for a moment
forcing arena's knight to
the a4 square where it's a little bit
offsides but in return
there's this nice c4 square that this
bishop could come to
and um black still has to show
how she's going to get compensation for
her pawn
indeed this uh looks like perhaps a
melakina trying to mix things up but
maybe not the best choice against as you
said such an experienced player
she's going to to be like oh my god i've
never seen this move before
right right right let's take a look at
our other tournament leader anna
zadonski how's he doing
and while i do that i'll say somebody
who once i think uh
who wants perhaps a prize because
somebody just typed into the u.s chess
champs
hashtag um just wondering how jennifer
seems to look more pretty every year and
yasser looks younger
we drink the blood of pawns
okay wow uh
hey he didn't mention maurice
it's sad your ties get cooler looking
every year
all right thanks jen i appreciate it
right well with that let's take our
first commercial break and then we'll
take a look at that zatanski game
wonderful
be surprised be intrigued be
delighted the world chess hall of fame
in st
louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together
the world chess hall of fame mind art
experience
and we're back and that was a commercial
for fat chimp studios a very cool
commercial by the way i like watching
that
that's right and of course also one for
the world chess hall of fame and uh
we're going to be doing an event there
uh tomorrow actually
reunion it's a recreation of a marcel
duchamp john cage match and
we'll be telling you a little bit more
about that later in the show but
with no further ado let's take a look at
anna zatonski playing against her friend
camilla beckham skyki today
absolutely and these women have had
tremendous
battles over the years camilla being a
veteran
in these women's events defending with
the black pieces
having a difficult go in this year's
2014
u.s women's championship anna knows that
friend or
foe she needs a win to keep pace with
arena
and of course if she could take the lead
over arena she would be
elated with that playing the white
pieces
queen's gambit declined again very very
solid choices we've seen many grand
masters
in both the open and women's section
enjoying
this defense with black c7
c5 okay this is a little bit of a
surprise
going into a line and i forgot the name
of it that bobby fisher liked to play
when he was black
in his younger days he liked to try to
trade off a couple pairs of pieces very
early
with this bishop before check ideas
and he would go for
this position as black yeah it's
escaping
my eyes the name of the defense
dartmouth they can hashtag us at usgs
and help us
uh anna felt that her chances of winning
the
winning the game by going into that
ending weren't particularly
good so she played the quiet answer
e2 e3 and as we can see at this exact
moment
on the board we have a symmetrical
position
white has a hard time using her extra
tempo one of the
points from black's point of view is as
soon as white moves her bishop
then black will capture and it will cost
white a tempo to recapture that pawn so
white needs a good move here it's like a
pass move
the two the the move i know best
is what ana played a2 a3
and there is the secondary move this
this leap into the center
with knight f3 to e5 i think a283 is the
best chance of getting an
edge and a7 a6 takes on c5
and we're here the the normal
continuation would be bishop takes c5
b4 bishop a7
bishop b2 castles and a lot of games
have gone from this exact position i
don't know what the winning percentages
are for either side
but in principle it's a balanced game
so good opening play by rahan skyty and
we should mention that yesterday she
wasn't
able to manage to draw that game against
melakina where right she was really on
the rope so
probably tired and going to be looking
forward to the rest day tomorrow but
first she's going to give it her best
against her friend ana zatonski these
two they
they have breakfast together in the
morning i wonder if they did today
maybe they took the day off yeah yeah
from breakfast
we've got a maurice ashley with actually
a game that really intrigued me in the
u.s championship not one
at the top of the standings but we got
to look at our night our sicilians
of course it's fact in fact it's the
only sicilian of the day so you know
we've got to look at it
because it's so exciting but there's
some real exciting games going on right
now
i just want to show something really
quickly in this particular position
uh this game between ehrenberg and
mullner we have a night of sicilian with
a knight g4 this line made popular by
gary kasparov back in the day so this
line going
up to this position bishop b6 queen d2
just developing pieces
we see that black has compromised this
side of the board just a bit
but it's right here that it gets
interesting after the move queen a5 and
a3 defending the pawn castles
and now we have castles on opposite side
of the board
and white played the move h4 now this
one's saying
i'm over here you're over here i'm
trying to get at you
with my pawns i'd like to switch to a
position i've only i was only able to
find
uh two games in this line uh let me see
right here
nope it was right here is the other game
this game played previously
in moscow in 2001 between two lower
rated players
but really interesting uh finish the way
white won this
it actually was because black didn't
notice this move coming up
right here queen e5 h5 knight f4 g3
chasing the knight
the knight dropped back and take a look
at this queen trap
rook to d5 suddenly the queen is trapped
in the middle of the board
if it moves to f6 then simply rook f5
and the queen has absolutely nowhere to
go well
we didn't expect our players in these
championships
to fall for that line here of course
instead of doing that mackenzie mullner
played the move
knight to c4 instead of bishop c4 and
after this trade he traded
on d4 queen takes and now rook takes
with a tempo so this position here
next move we expect is queen e3 should
be slightly better for white because of
black's compromise position
but black has his pluses as well with
the open c file
jumping to another game though that
actually is much more interesting
than this one is this position
if i can oh here we go shanklin against
naraditsky now this one had a crazy
position they they came out of uh
a king's indian i believe king's indian
they transposed out of a king's indian
but take a look at the last couple of
moves
in this position here shanklin decided
to play the move knight to d5
just gifting the pawn on b2 and you
wonder well what's the deal
and after bishop takes b2 attacking the
rook shanklin played
g4 on the other side of the board well
of course you can't touch this rook
because
this position could end up to be really
bad after
queen takes on a1 and suddenly if you
move the knight you can't put it here
because
the white queen and knight are attacking
it and if you put it here
then bishop to h6 and your dark squares
are toast knight f6 check coming
whenever he wants it
this position is horrible for him uh i
mean you have to throw something in the
way maybe rookie five but after bishop
takes king takes
f4 is not looking comfortable to say the
least
so after g4 naradisky
had to drop back with this move and then
rook to b1
uh wait a second i think he played yes
rook to b1
attacking the bishop and now the bishop
had to retreat it is now on f6
and the computer is saying compensation
the b file
the dark squares he can take this
whenever he wants he has c5 as threats
a crazy position without any stability
because the pawns
are crazy for white and he's down a pawn
but he's got tons of activity so this
position is definitely heating up
so early we see two games of sicilian
and this one that shanklin has
and he sacrificed the pawn he knew he
was sacrificing the pawn he's committed
the move g4
and now he's thinking about it
interesting chess
right now in the championships back to
you guys
well thank you for that maurice uh
provocation at its best there by daniel
norenski he provoked his opponent into
playing knight d5 sacrificing the pawn
but now he's going to have to face a
very uh
dangerous uh initiative by
uh white and um
great it's gonna be a great great battle
indeed and uh you know
you were talking the other day about how
you love gary kasparov's facial
expressions
yes and how most of the players here are
more poker face more stoic
i think shanklin's a bit of an exception
he has some pretty awesome faces
he does like the chess base uh in the
report of this tournament used
in chess 24 too they used the the
picture of
him in the game yesterday because it was
just awesome
right he looked uh he looked real mean
yeah
down i'd i mean in a totally
understandable
chess way it's not in a human being way
just kind of similar to onasho
he looks like such a tiger on the board
but in person sweet as to me
absolutely the guy who had the greatest
glare of all times of course
was michael tall an absolutely marvelous
human being
but at the board an absolute killer and
he had this
he had the glare that i just can't even
bring myself close to duplicating
but when he uh stared at you
and he made this intent look upon you
you really had your
feeling like oh what did i do wrong
trying to make a good layer of hair
it's hard though it's hard to do it just
like at this point right
but uh yeah i guess that's a good thing
for for uh for people that
you know chess is an excuse to hate
somebody for a few hours
yeah don't be hating generally
we've got something from maurice and
another one of our games
ramirez and for now indeed some
wild chess going on this round guys you
brought up mikhail tal
and here's a position that was a
tactical idea that was
featured in one of his games check out
this open real lopez
that ramirez is playing against friedel
and in this position
black played the move after rookie one
the move d4
almost trapping the bishop and after
bishop to f4 he played
g5 trying to chase the bishop away maybe
pushing into the g3 square
but guess what in this position ramirez
decided
to sacrifice the bishop and after bishop
takes bishop
knight takes on g5 you got to wonder
what's the point of this idea
isn't that a whole piece well hold your
horses because this does happen
in many variations or at least in one
specific variation
of the real lopez where in this moment
white can play the move queen to f3
down a piece looks like he's sacrificing
another but there's tactics down here
with these nice
queen c6 check to the rook and right now
the only way to defend the knight
properly remember this pawn is hanging
to this bishop if you move your bishop
back then you're sensitive let's call it
sensitive on this square after a bishop
takes
f7 check where do you put the king and
now this e
pawn turns into a beast going down the
board and black's position
is blown up so black's only option here
is actually a reasonable option let's
call it is to move king to d7
and here white can continue pace with
the move bishop
to d5 and suddenly the knight is under
attack
cannot be defended if bishop takes
bishop of course queen takes on d5
with check and one of these knights if
not
both are going to drop so a really
interesting sacrifice right here
the move g5 lighting up the chess board
i wonder if he anticipated this
sacrifice coming back at him
and now white is currently up upon for
the moment i don't think he can
even avoid taking this knight back
having walked into the line
he's now got to deal with the fire so
really interesting games
starting already here at the
championships guys
all right that you're committed once
you've played the move g5
i'm sure because this idea of the
sacrifice is so very well known
from michael tall and that the players
are familiar with it
i know that smeslov also liked to play
the black side of the open rui as of
course did victor korchnoy
and these lines tend to be very tactical
very sharp and so it's going to come
down to
who is better prepared we have a monster
game going on on board one between our
defending champion
godakamsky playing what we call the
king's
indian attack but with the white pieces
wow
you were kind of right in a way alex
remember in the kamsky lenderman
game you predicted one e4 right and then
i laughed about how you couldn't be more
wrong
and we've transposed now
exactly you get this out of the french
as well as the sicilian this very very
uh position that we have on the board
and it is wild
on h6 because on one hand it's great
because it sets up potential checkmates
and
on the other hand it's so forward
that it kind of interferes with white
pieces attacking and getting a minor
piece attack going what do you think a
positive or negative
positive positive we'll we'll see it in
just a moment let me show the our
audience how we got here
because they have played very quickly
the game started
in a slow fashion
white gata just built what i call
a fortress position uh fianchetto and
his bishop
putting his king behind the bishop i
used to love to do this as a kid
it was described to me as the fortress
formation
and it became a favorite in in my games
castles and we're right back into a
french defense
close french position knight c6 and so
what
so what black is doing is
getting an edge over here on the queen
side
but white thanks to his pawn on the e5
gets a pretty nice he gets to press in
the center
and whenever you force away this
defending knight
that the knight on f6 that defends
black's king
there's always possibilities of a
kingside checkmating attack
knight f1 all of these moves are very
have been played before very familiar to
those of you who
have studied bobby fischer's games this
was a favorite
attacking line and that bobby light
now bobby like to hang back a little bit
with this move h5 what he bobby
liked to do first of first of was to
maneuver this knight to g4
right to get those minor pieces in to
get the minor pieces in
as well as to keep this pawn on e5
really really nicely defended
and then at when at the right time
sometimes you want to trade dark square
bishop
gotta just went for it right away he
played h5
a4 again you see black gaining space
over here on the queen side
now the reason this has such a different
character and i think that bobby liked
this as compared to other
lines of the french is that we don't
have a plot on d4 so there's not as much
easy counter play for black
of course there's counter play but it
comes a little bit slower like you're
not going to
you know win up win my pawns on a2 and
v2 c and c2 so easily it's going to take
you some time
right so in a sense jen when white has a
pawn on d4 it's a target
with the pawn on d3 it's kind of hard
it's harder
for black to get concrete counter play
in the center so
quickly so it's it's
come see kamsa you're the pawn on d4
like as well
right because now we do have a bigger
difficulty defending e5 which is of
course
the crux of our position we lose that we
lose everything everything goes wrong
so there goes uh gotta charging down the
board now this pawn on h6
um at times you know it can be
interfere the way of white's attack like
white might think if
boy if it was my move in this position i
would like to play the move bishop on c1
captures h6 and bring my bishop
into uh but that's illegal
as there's a small detail but so
sometimes the pawn on h6 can
interfere with white's attack but on the
other
side the pawn on h6 greatly restricts
black's king
and you always have to you always have
this uncomfortable feeling
that there's lurking threats like
there's a danger
uh to your king but then the question is
how does white really
increase his advantage now because i
mean obviously knight h2 to g4
but then one well exactly to queen to f4
like you see that kind of maneuver
sometimes happened trying to get that
queen into the game
but well exactly so the point is this
knight on
h2 desperately desperately wants to go
to g4
and from g4 to take an additional hop
skip and a jump to the f6 square where
it would be tremendous
but at the moment black has two
defenders of the f6 square
first the knight on d7 d7 second the
bishop on e7
so i would anticipate that what gata
would do
is to play first bishop f4 and then i
don't know i'm just going to put a move
on the board for a moment rook c8
queen d2 so what white is trying to do
is he wants to maneuver his knight to g4
he wants to move his bishop to g5
remove this defender of the f6 square
and to maintain a kind of presence
if you will over on the king side in the
meantime
black has to be very careful that he
doesn't misplay
his hand on the queen side for example
there are times when you play c4
too early and after the move d4 if you
don't get in
the counter attacking move c2 c4 c3
in just the right way what can turn out
that your whole
exercise on the queen side is a complete
loss of time
and white will have a tremendous
position so a real clash of styles
going on in this crucial game to our
standings in the 2014 u.s championships
yeah we could have asked for more
especially after we see knight of three
and g3 in the first moves
right it might be super quiet but a very
interesting positional struggle i think
we'll we'll see here so
that'll be fun and let me just go and
see what's happening in
rob's and of course yes exactly today
our other co-leader and it looks like a
catalan
has appeared on our board ray robson
playing
the unexpected opening moved
d4 as wide
var went for his standard queens gambit
declined position
saying what do you what do you ray have
prepared and g2 g3
is kind of becoming a popular move to
fianchetto our bishop
we've seen this by gauriev we've seen it
by kamsky
and um well one of the most popular
defenses so
no surprise to var bishop before check
very standard move in the catalan
it's it looks at first blush
that you're giving white the extra tempo
bishop d2
but what black is really saying is that
your bishops actually
misplaced on d2 and that's why we're
seeing this
check and retreat all right
after castles c7 c6
notice that black just clogs up the
center with these
with this clump of pawns in the middle
of the board to
to keep the bishop on g2 blocked
so it's not an effective bishop queen c2
defending the pawn on c4 knight d7
all very very standard moves seen many
times
funny ray gets the tempo back here
he plays bishop f4 back to c1 knight d2
b3 and we've seen many many
games from this position usually bishop
b7
bishop b2 rook c8
rook c1 or d1 c6 c5
queen b1 we've seen a lot of these
games they're real trench warfare kind
of games
and i have seen a lot of draws come out
of this
uh opening unfortunately sad to say
okay so balanced position not quite
exactly what we were
hoping for in this game but as we've
seen in the championship you never know
when a game is going to blow up
exactly we don't know and they're just
building up maurice
share some thoughts of your own with us
please
talk about a game that has blown up well
we saw the sacrifice
on g5 and ramirez versus friedel and
friedel did take the knight on g5 and
uh and queen f3 move was played so just
going back just a quick second
right here after that that wild move g5
right here g5 and then
white sacrificed on g5 and then bishop
takes and knight takes
and then now we see queen takes happen
and after queen to f3
friedel had a very good continuation he
could have played
very solid according to the computer
king to d7
would have been a nice line to play here
and after
bishop to d5 it would have been no
problem at all
to just play knight takes on e5
attacking this queen that's defending
this bishop
white would have a counter blow rook
takes on e5
queen takes and now you could take the
rook
in the corner but in this position the
computer says cool calm
just move your king off of this
sensitive check square
out of that square and why can't keep
the initiative going
rookie one is not playable black always
has pressure
on the back row maybe even play rook g8
coming down this way
so this position should be okay for
black
easy for houdini to say fridell
after seeing queen f3 didn't like those
lines moving his king up the board king
d7 you're definitely not taught to do
that in chess
instead he played the move knight to d8
and this is the position
that ramirez is thinking about this line
houdini doesn't like because of queen
takes rook queen takes knight and now
this rook
to d1 and there's pressure on the d-pawn
all the way through
to the rook to the knight on d8 so
not so great a position for black it
seems in this moment
having chosen not to go for the sharper
line bringing the king into the game he
might face some difficulties but you see
there ramirez
thinking about the position trying to
figure out if he should just grab that
rook
back to you guys thank you maurice yeah
yeah how deep do you think the
preparation is here
that's a good guess for ramirez
certainly this line is a surprise for
him
i think he's he's likely been on his own
since the move g5 of course he'll be
familiar with a lot of the patterns but
not necessarily the specifics
in the case of josh i would be really
surprised if his
preparation he if he
hadn't already uh foreseen this
position on his board i agree because
he's the one
initiating the action with g5 agreed and
the reason i say i say that also is it
seems to me that
if fernell hadn't looked at this earlier
he would have spent more than uh
20 minutes up to now right i mean just
because it's just such a critical
position that like if you're just like
oh yeah 98 u.s championship i have an
hour and a half left in the clock who
cares
this looks good you know and just throw
it out there no
no no no that being said he's prepping
with computers so
interesting that he's deviating from the
houdini evaluation
at the same time maybe kind of similar
variations anyway a puzzle that
we will continue to solve as the round
goes on
and and by the way in this situation
when you're in ramirez's shoes
you have this very unpleasant
feeling this unpleasant sensation that
your opponent has out prepared you
somehow
and you're fearful that you're going to
fall into a specific
line that your opponent has prepared and
you end up double checking and trouble
checking your calculations
to be sure that you're not being
ambushed
you do have this unpleasant feeling of
surprise in the opening
but yet the position is looking okay for
white in that variation that maurice
demonstrated so we'll keep a close eye
on this one and we are going to take our
our first uh commercial or our first
break of the day our fischer commercial
break of the day
oh we get a fisher puzzle that's right
so you guys you've got a
another bobby fischer puzzle to solve
during the break so
we never want to let you cross too much
right you got to keep thinking
throughout the whole broadcast
we'll be back in just a bit for more
from the u.s championship and u.s
women's here in st louis
so
so
do
14 u.s chess championship and u.s
women's here in saint louis
will alexander on ashoka yes
just so he saw him there in our screen
and i'm telling you i'm going to steal
some thunder from
maurice but the game between naraditsky
and shanklin
has really heated up in this round seven
that's right and some games heating up
early but first let's take a look at our
our fischer puzzle the answer there was
work to be one
rook to b1 with the idea of work to b7
and we have maurice ashley on the
details on that and
he was playing against a friend of yours
right right
he's such a cool man oh yeah well duncan
was such a cool player too
well the move rook to b1 the key move
here
sort of the only move if you look at it
it's just it's the
file that you want to be on is that b
file and the problem for
black is that he can't touch this a pawn
which he did actually
he but if he leaves it on the board he's
in big trouble
as well so he decided to play queen
takes a4
and then fischer dropped a hammer down
with the move queen to
f8 and the main point of rogue b1 was
revealed
it wasn't to play this check and see
what could happen it was to put a rook
on b8
and mate the king and that move ended
the show
after rook to g7 rook to b8 with the
threat of queen to h8 mate
black was desperate now just tossing a
pawn to g5
and here came the checks queen h8
king to g6 and now queen to f
tweet to e8 with check and now what do
you do you don't want to drop your pawn
here
by moving your king and also the e6 pawn
is going with check
and just throwing moves out now he
played rook f7 and suddenly rook to b7
appeared
and that was all she wrote so a powerful
victory
by bobby fischer i'm sorry as over your
good friend duncan
suttles but fischer used to do it
against everybody's friends
for sure but going back to what you were
talking about as well if we may
the game between shanklin and naraditsky
is crazy look at this after sacrificing
the b-pawn
now shanklin is trying to thrust his
pawns
down naradiski's throat throwing these
pawns forward f5 g5
he has now played on the board so he's
thinking only one thing
kill kill kill that's it after
sacrificing his pawn
so this one will indeed be a barn burner
we'll keep our eye on these
two young players here at the
championships back to you guys
well we're seeing the king's indian
defense it has so many resources daniel
naradiski looks fairly comfortable his
provocative play
he grabbed this b2 pawn early gave white
a lot of tempe to go for this king side
assault
houdini isn't buying it at all by the
way it thinks that black is doing just
fine
but it is a frightening looking attack
i'm thinking that daniel is probably
going to just simply play a move like b7
b6
anticipating f4 f5 and knight c5
daniel calculating the variations in his
mind he
probably is feeling pretty good about
his position even though
he does have a slightly worried
expression now let's take a look at our
big game today versus lenderman
fascinating strategic battle
we were a little worried that it might
turn out to be dry but instead
we've got two competing strategies one
on the king side one on the queen side
you know that usually is bad news for
the king but
not always no sometimes the uh the the
blackets at a queenside breakthrough as
well
so it looks like black is kind of
mirrored right
we talked earlier about the pros and
cons of getting that pawn to h6
right and you talked about how fischer
sometimes started with knight h2 to g4
kanski has gotten his knight to g4
anyway but
what interests me is landerman has
achieved
the mirroring move a3
which locks down white's pawn
and now the pawn on c2 is a potential
target
oh absolutely black will do everything
in his power
to double and triple uh his major pieces
on the c
file to tie white down to that pawn on c
two that's right because the first if
you do it twice we'll probably play rook
to e2 so just like
rook to c8 and queen to c7 will be
well enough met by rookie too but god
has got to be thinking
how does he break through on the king
side because it's clear
that lenderman has this open c file for
his play
the question from goddess point of view
is
can he ever achieve success
in in um conquering
the square uh f6 well it sure seems
pretty well defended i was thinking of
something like queen to d2 to queen f4
kind of
maneuver you sometimes see in the french
but the thing is even in that case the
s6 square
is well defended so here gotta actually
just played a move
which um looks a bit strange he actually
retreated his knight back to h2
so let's puzzle that one out wow well
again is that an admission that his
position's not that good
no uh it's it's a it's
it's a closed position so there's a
there's a big maneuvering game ahead
um from goddess point of view
uh there is a structural defect in the
position
from black and that is black has these
double pawns on
d5 and d4 so in ghada's mind
if he if he as white could win this pawn
on d4
that would be a great success so his
idea with the move
with the retreating move knight h2 is
actually he wants to come with his
knight to f3
attacking this pawn on d4 and on a very
good day
he could do it first with the move queen
g4
because now the g4 square not being
occupied the queen could potentially
come across either d4
that's right getting the queen into the
game is so key that's why i was trying
to go queen d2 to f4
right right actually but here you like
this because now you're putting extra
pressure on d4
well it's all about a calculation one of
the
uh moves that gotta was
likely considering was like you said if
you want to try to
activate your queen you could go queen
f3 with the idea of queen f4 on your
next turn as well right
but one other benefit i just i
do like i do like very much ghada's move
by the way
knight h2 another benefit of this move
knight h2
is that in case
you're not able to capture this pawn on
d4 you do
have the maneuver rookie 2 knight f3
knight u1 uh
for for sure and forever and ever are
men because i was kind of worried about
the timing here like suppose we play
rook c8 here so
okay maybe you can't play queen g4 right
away well
exactly and if you play rookie two it
blocks your path
right um g4 so i thought that might be
kind of annoying because if you play
knight f3
then that also blocks your path to g4
true i was thinking that what white
would do was play a move like bishop f4
and if black played queen c7 putting
instant pressure on the pawn on c2
by developing my bishop
out of the way i i make room for this
move
rook c1 and now when you play queen g4
you might be thinking
at some point about playing bishop to g5
right and thinking about occupying those
dark squares
exactly another another simple
approach um is to play queen to d2 to
bishop to g5
knight to f3 so a definite
battling of ideas here who's going to
get their
soonest with moses is white slow
maneuvering on the king side going to
pay dividends
or is this pawn on c2 really so
handicapped that black's counter play on
the queen side
uh decides the game wow we've been
seeing a lot of good nice retreating uh
night moves right yesterday
knight be one decided and uh for del
gara from here
playing this knight h2 move which can't
be the first candidate for
most chess players but um maurice
actually has something for us in a game
that
it's not as much about maneuvering i
believe a little bit more of a slashing
game in the women's championship
a critical game for the women's
championship because arena crush is
trying
to keep her lead alive at least tied
with anna zatonski
she wants to make sure that she doesn't
slip back in this round
but she might have already slipped up in
this line we saw blumenfell
start this line off and alyssa malachina
not doing great in this tournament
but yesterday she had a game against
camilla began skyta where she played
a banco gambit and had a winning
position on the board
and missed it so these kind of positions
she's used to
gambling the pawn in order to get
counter play so she likes this as black
and she got into this line and here she
goes playing the move a6 a lot of the
banco gambit although we're in a
blumenfeld and in this position
houdini preferred the move b6 for white
here
but instead white captured on a6
and after knight takes bishop to c4
knight back
to c7 she played the move b3 and now
houdini is saying believe it or not
down a pawn is black at the moment
black's better
houdini likes black in this position all
the play on this side
that black will have black will also
someday get a knight on the d5 square
which will be a monster piece
always threatening to come into c3 but
houdini is saying just play simple chess
just play bishop e7 and castles and
black will have a dream position
this bishop on this wonderful diagonal
cutting through the position
this is going to be trouble if i had
this position i'd want black
for sure you just look at it all those
great open lines
it's the kind of position that's
attacking players dream so i think that
as calm as irina looks right now in a
few moves she's going to start wondering
what she did
to get in the situation in these
championships back to you guys
wow that is really a surprise for me
that arena didn't play the move b7 b6
because that move b5 b6 pardon me
stuffing black's counter play on the
queen side it just begs to be played
i'll agree with houdini big time on this
one because i really like
malaquina's b7 bishop and when
she gets a safe king after castles
arena is going to have to face some
serious threats
both to her king side as well as
her center she has played the move
bishop f4
in response to the expected move bishop
e7
and now castles comes with a tempo
against the bishop
let me just bring that position up on
on our screens i was going to go to a
different game but this one is certainly
an exciting
battle a pitch battle sure and critical
for the women's championship
absolutely as our um
perennial champions irina crush and anna
zatonski arena in a little bit of
trouble coming
out of the opening here we've just seen
her play
essentially what maurice was saying and
what i was
also saying as well is this
bishop is attacking this knight on f3
the knight on f3 is the only defender of
this pawn on e5
so bishop f4 certainly an
understandable move wanting to reinforce
the defense of the center pawn e5 but
after
castles the rook the open the half open
f-file
the rook attacks the bishop with the
tempo
arena will likely have to drop back with
her bishop on g3
and here black has an opportunity
of doubling the pawns on
f3 and f2 which makes it a little bit
more awkward for white's king
the problem from black is that she needs
to bring her queen over here there's no
reason to rush with this bishop takes f3
move by the way uh plenty of good
reasons for wanting to
stick the knight on d5 and bringing it
to f4
but i like these creepy crawly moves of
just bringing
the queen to a powerful position over
here on the king side trying to generate
threats
and indeed threats like rook takes f3
appear
quite quickly in these uh fast attacks
and that bishop on g3 doesn't end up
leaving much of an impression doesn't it
except it does make a diff you know it's
a star wars defender
uh but it's not a great uh piece
except for the fact that it is a good
defending piece
another standard idea that we see in
such positions is exchange sacrifices
time and time again
uh we love these types of exchange
sacrifices
what black is playing for bishop takes
f3
arena is going to have to go into a
defensive huddle
like bishop e2 to keep the pawn on f3
keep in mind that
bishop is an ambush for that rook so you
can't advance the f pawn
and then after move like queen f5
castles rook f8 black's game
in a certain sense plays itself
the bishop on g3 could also be a target
for a h5h4 idea
uh i know maurice this is a lot of fun
exactly exactly this is not a lot of fun
for white
well he wants to get the queens traded
asap but alyssa of course would have
been happy about that
we'll avoid queen queen traits for sure
and again i don't know if arena's aware
of the
uh approaching danger but 5 10 15 moves
down the road
uh her king could get into real trouble
great this this game and the women's
championship is uh
really getting exciting yeah two players
hide at the top and
not having an even easy time of it even
with the white pieces and last time we
checked the bahan sky t satonski that
game was also balanced
right guys if i may add there's one
weakness
that the champion has shown irina crush
his one weakness
is underestimating her opponent's
attacking potential
she said it herself that sometimes she
gets in trouble because
she thinks everything is hunky-dory and
then all of a sudden her position is
under heavy
assault so that could be an issue in
this game
she may have or may not have misjudged
this position maybe she's still
fine houdini certainly likes black's
opportunities here
in this position but these are the kind
of things you'd expect houdini in this
kind of position
to misjudge closed positions not this
kind of open position
it sees tactics like crazy but then
again alyssa is no houdini
so she still has to find moves and
figure out even the attacking lines that
you talked about yes
but she's she's got to be happy with the
kind of position she has
because these kinds of positions are the
ones she plays for
sacrificing upon for active initiative
guys and also let's be clear uh
alyssa's a big underdog in this game
she's playing black against a five-time
champion and so why not
go attack mad do a little sacrificing
mix it up
early and put the pressure on her
opponent she has
castled i am anticipating that
retreating move bishop g3
and then the big money move will she
come up with rook takes f3
forcing uh arena crush
um onto the defense i think she's
considering it you know it's kind of it
pops up at you
will she play it does she have uh faith
in her attacking ability
uh to really put pressure on arena
i've pulled up the game between sam
shanklin and bishop g3 very
quickly played by arena i pulled up the
game between sam shankland and daniel
noroditsky once more
because this is one of those games where
i like provoking my opponent
to try to go mad hog on the king side
daniel's got a
pawn in his pocket already and now
he's just got to figure out how he's
going to handle
this initiative on the king side i'm
thinking that daniel should start with
the move b7 b6
the reason for that move is first of all
you want to
blunt the pressure against the pawn on
b7 that releases the bishop not that
it's going anywhere anytime soon
but another reason why you want to play
that move is because
after for example f4f5
the knight takes up a beautiful outpost
on the c5 square which
by the way from the c5 square the pawn
on e4 is under a double attack
by both rook and knight and this is a
game
where sam could really be falling on his
own sword here
in his attempts to getting
an overwhelming kingside attacking
position he may go too far
and find himself suddenly in trouble
that's right we've got some early action
going on in that game
let's take a look at kamsky lenderman
okay we go back to our
board one and by the way
gada is going to be happy with the
outcome that we're seeing here
remember we were talking about his
desire that is to say
goddess desire to to trade dark square
bishops
in the position i have on my screen yes
he's just
exactly so after rook to c8 we were
wondering
um whether what he was gonna we were
expecting that after rook ca
you mentioned i think knight f3 as well
and going after this pawn on d4 by the
way
uh alex uh took the a time out to
defend the pawn on uh d4 with his queen
and now after bishop to g5 so gotta
immediately
playing bishop to g5 rather than we were
thinking maybe bishop f4 queen d2 would
come into the position at some point
but he got the immediate bishop g5 can
black avoid the trade of bishops what if
black just plays
for instance i mean there's only one way
to do it bishop c5
but it looks kind of weird right like
well it's got zero scope for your bishop
you're protecting a pawn that is only
attacked once
well the real problem with avoiding the
bishop
exchange is what you do to your own
counter play against the c2 pawn now you
have to move your queen away and your
bishop
way to get any play on that pawn exactly
so
uh for better for worse uh alex
acquiesced
to the trade of bishops bishop takes g5
knight takes g5
now it's fun that how we have a weakness
on c2 and
they have weakness on f7 exactly so you
see this uh
this really aesthetic mirroring going on
here but now here's the key
question can black play queen c7
with this time with a double attack
against the pawn on
e5 as well as an attack against the pawn
on c2
now we could even consider a move like
queen to f3 here because
i think that knight takes e5 is off the
cards because of queen to f6
with a forced mate right and at the same
time i'm not so sure about queen takes
c2 either
but i was looking yeah i guess queen
pixy the problem is that also
attacks d3 so that's going to be pretty
strong one of the tactics that are
always lurking in this type of position
generally
bishop takes c5 you constantly have to
calculate the consequences of these
types of sacrifices
because black's king is always
vulnerable that pawn on h78
on h6 always restricts the black king
i'm not saying bishop takes d5 is a good
move in this type in this position
it seems that after takes on e6 we
should be adequately defending
don't you think yes i do because we're
going to get the two pieces for the rook
just give up i think what you want you
want to get
with the queen exactly right this is the
type of thing that i'm looking at is if
i can get in the queen takes g4
and on a very good day of course i've
got a a
checkmate oops pardon me checkmate
served up on the board
so again after the move queen c7
attacking this pawn on d4 uh totally
attacking the part only a totally
different type of
variation may occur how about this one
okay i appreciate that queen f3
i wasn't happy about queen take c2 here
i was thinking about queen d2
queen takes c2 by no means the only move
by the way
queen takes b4 and suddenly the position
is being ripped apart a lot of pawn
weaknesses for both players the spawn on
d3
pawn on a3 pawn on d4 are all
targets and this could get to be
quite a crazy looking position the fun
thing about queen b4 is now your bishop
takes d5
starts after after e6 takes on e6 we
might
suddenly jump in with queenie be careful
of the f2 pawn but precisely right
you can maybe a preface it with queen e7
and
bishop d5 and e6 but absolutely right
also in this position let me just make a
i don't want to say this is a bad move
for black but same ideas jen
queen drops into e7 hello give me your
knight
if your knight gets defended then
there's this knight takes e6 and again
f7 was just hanging off oh i beg your
pardon let's do it again
let's do it in a different manner then
pardon me the other rook to c7
let's say rook to c7 defending the
knight and guess what
bang knight takes e6 and you can't play
f takes e6 because of this uh
checkmate to go
referencing the chess to go yeah the boy
scouts
project that genie zinfield oh genie the
one where
the the the chess set that you can just
put in your pocket is it your campaign
right right yeah i love those they're
great absolutely
and uh we've actually got an event
tomorrow with the girl scouts
so we're gonna be going to ballpark
village in saint louis and we're gonna
be doing a human chess match with
uh some of the girl scouts playing the
different pieces really
so could i play and order the girls to
go
and capture one another then i think
that's basically what's gonna happen
that's right so always trying to get
more girls into chess wanted to be
closer to 50 50 don't we
and by the way again i've said it so
many times
a real shout out to jeannie and what she
managed to to achieve with boy scouts of
america
getting the merit badge recognition that
was a
huge huge breakthrough for chess we it
was something that bobby fischer tried
in the 60s when he wrote his column for
the boy scouts of america magazine
but never got the merit badge uh jeannie
made that happen so
fantastic and uh yes i love chester
that's
great they even have the paper wands
right so you can give it out to a whole
whole
chess class and it costs like a quarter
to make or something like that exactly
chess sets for a quarter jeannie uh
designed
and created that whole chess set by the
way
i watched it in its infancy and its
development
and um well magnus was playing with it
at the sinkfield cup and uh i think
it was the opening ceremony and there
was
it was actually a very funny game it was
at the dinner
and this was hilarious because on his
team on magnus's team
was our uh beneficiary um
benefactor pardon me uh rex singfield
and so rex is really happy having magnus
carlsen as his
as his partner and guess what magnus
blundered a rook
during the game we wanted to come back
for the next year
and rex was like what is this guy doing
i'm
rescinding the replacement i mean that
was terrible the rex was horrified
that the world champion he needs a
better partner obviously
he's got standards and we have maurice
ashley for
something on a crush malakina has that
game progressed
the game has not progressed however your
move yes
is so up my alley that i had to look at
it and
no doubt melahina is also looking at it
but what's interesting is that
houdini is not looking at it at all
take a look at this position you can't
see right here the list of
possible moves that houdini's analyzing
it thinks bishop to c6
is the best move in this position
however
i asked it to go down to 10 different
options and it's suggesting moves like
rook to a5
queen to e8 all kinds of other moves
where it says black is either better or
equal
but i said what about rook f3 and as
soon as i put it on the board it goes
oh yeah that's good too you could do
that if you want
because after pawn takes queen f8 is its
first move
and suddenly this pressure along this
diagonal
is immense and intense
if you defend the pawn with bishop to e2
then
this move knight to d5 and you just look
at black's position
and you love it just on face value this
king has no
real home to go to in the long run moves
like
h5 as you said he has h4 will be threats
the f5 will blow up
this sacrifice is certainly possible for
black
giving black multiple options here to be
able to attack
white's king or at least put pressure on
white's position so the exchange sack
is certainly an interesting move she has
not played it
however she played the move rook to f5
and if i back up and look at the list
that one's not on houdini's list either
but i'll play it on the board rook to f5
and
houdini's saying that's good too so
there you go
clearly black's position is absolutely
fine it's all going to depend on how she
handles herself
but i think that irina crush will soon
feel the pressure in this position when
she realizes
that she has no advantage despite being
up a pawn
back to you guys that's right and you
know irena crush
earlier in her career used to be famous
for getting into massive time pressure
but yesterday in her interview with
grandmaster and maurice ashley she said
you know what i actually don't get in
the time pressure that much anymore she
solved it
right but when she doesn't like her
position she does right which is
kind of just a natural and oftentimes
logical reaction
if you play too quickly and you just
play quick moves even when you don't
like your position then you know you're
gonna lose
right so i think the fact that she's
already used
um a lot of time she's behind melissa on
the clock and a lot of those moves were
opening moves
shows that just like yesterday against
tatev she's not that happy
no and we might see another type of
time scramble as we get towards the time
control and that's not good for her
although
yesterday she found a lot of good moves
versus thought that despite having very
little time in her class her clock would
tick down to i think about five seconds
and one particular moment these accurate
moves like king h7
you know just saving the day right
exactly so
uh she's under pressure again um tough
one going on there
let me just check uh some of our
okay we did not see by the way that that
very
um aggressive move uh queen
c7 with the double attack that we've
been mentioning
in the lenderman goddakamsky game
instead
we saw this normal i'm not going to say
a plotting move because it
definitely fits with the whole concept
that black has
which he lenderman wants to do of course
is to double rooks putting pressure on
that pawn on c2 and as you were saying
there's a mirror type of recipes
i'm gonna say represent reciprocity yes
just don't ask me to say it three times
okay i promise i do this once was good
enough though
yes you you you you're channeled
and in case i don't like precisely
rook c8 if you go after my pawn well
i'll go after
this f7 isn't that a good trade c2 for
f7
big time white will sign sign up for
that one and
in a nanosecond and that's why if you
have a queen side attack
inherently it's supposed to be a little
bit stronger than the king side attack
precisely right that's why
you know in the king's indian and things
like that it's kind of like white's
getting there first but black's going
for checkmates
that's okay right so i'm thinking that
after rook c1 which is a it's just kind
of a prophylactic move
which allows you to keep that queen on
d1 open to f3 that's why
earlier we were looking at rookie 2
which in a way looks more harmonious but
not with the queen back we want that
queen in the game right
just uh by defending the pawn on c2 i'm
kind of releasing my queen
one of the things that always troubled
me when i got myself and i often got
myself into these positions as black by
the way
was the bishop on a6 on the first hand
you might look at that bishop and say
okay well it's on a nice diagonal blah
blah blah
but the reality is that both bishops are
not that effective the strange
part is that in these types of positions
white's bishop on h3 on g2 may not look
as effective
or they both look like passive bishops
but the reality is is that this bishop
on
h3 on g2 can sometimes pop out to h3
we've mentioned the bishop takes the
five sacrifices
and so this bishop on g2 is far more
effective than the bishop on d3
and black bishop on a6 you're you're
thinking that bishop d3 is almost never
in the cards never in the card
it's a very rare tactic that would exist
exactly only if we moved all over
both our queen on on d1 and are working
to e2 away oh wait which seems
unrealistic
exactly but you know the interesting
thing is that uh if black could change
that
bishop on a6 to a knight think about how
different the position would be we'd go
knight c7 knight b5 knight c3
and that's why they say that in close
positions like this the knights really
favor the bishops
right so i bet you you were a pretty
good uh
bug house player huh sort of like you
asked your opponent give me a knight
give me a knife
it would be great give me a knife so
exciting things still going on
there and i'll i'll check some of
the other top boards we haven't seen ray
robson in a while
and um the game
still looks fairly balanced here i was
saying that
the problem for this opening for white
it's a really kind of a slow
maneuvering game and we have seen a
trade of ponds
for those of you who are wondering
this queen on a1 looks like it's buried
on the queen side
but this battery that we're seeing along
the
b2 diagonal a lot of elite grand masters
have played for just this type of uh
queen on a1 instead of leading with the
queen
you lead with the bishop again i'm
seeing
that game is a little bit too balanced i
don't expect any fireworks in that game
how about irena's main rival on zatonski
how's she doing against camilla behind
skytee
uh good question i'll come right to that
in a moment but i'm looking at the game
between timor garriev
your man in red
uh yesterday you were you were a channel
channeling josh oh yeah and josh or
their channel
maybe the maybe the fashion statements
work
out for teamwork you know actually who
lent me these jackets
yesterday's jackets and this one susan
barrett at the world chess hall of fame
the fashionista yeah oh fantastic okay
so she's the guilty party okay
but let's see this game has gotten this
game has really exploded
like what the heck just happened these
very strong
players and crazy things have happened
how did that night get to
okay so we're way back here on g2 we
started off with the nimzo with g3 and
uh we were discussing that
the drawback of that is that c4 ends up
hanging in a lot of variations well
seymour said come and get it and well
timor said you keep it
instead of going after the pawn on c4
uh he played for the center e
center pawns d4 and e4 and
alex said well i will keep my extra pawn
and by the way now that this pawn is on
a3
that b3 square is not adequately
defended
so and he went knight b3
the rook slid over didn't want to lose
an exchange obviously
and c7c5 trying to break up the nice
team
in the center d d take c5 was played
knight g4 okay
uh things definitely getting exciting
suddenly here
knight g4 attacking the bishop the
bishop stepped
out knight takes c5
e4 e5 wow
okay alex traded queens before
timor had a chance to avoid that trait
queen takes rook takes knight d3 well
black's a pawn up and he's saying hey i
would like a second
h2h3 driving the knight
backwards big moment here he did go back
but i'm sure both players were busily
calculating the consequences
of this line and i'm i'm guessing that
both
players found that this variation was
favorable for white
so the knight went back but then
after the knight retreated bishop takes
h6
blowing up the king side these doubling
pawns on the h
file and what is our resulting position
like
b3 bishop takes and here we are today
i think we're caught up to date i'm
guessing that it's time for white to
start winning
some pawns back takes what do you think
say a knight d2
rook g4 and i don't know what's going
on um material
is whites down upon whites down upon but
black's king sight is all busted up
and uh rook g forecheck knight is just
totally
it had disharmony for black knight 94
knight f6
check if we talked about godakamski
trying to land a knight on f6
or take command of the f6 square
and white's got clear ideas i like the
extra pawn
but at the moment these pieces are
sleeping over here on
the uh king queenside and alex is going
to play
have to play some really good defensive
moves to
withstand the assault that timor has in
mind
well what if he tries to get his bishop
back to e7 to try to defend against that
a knight f6 move
i'm a little worried about that knight
on b2 as well because it doesn't have a
lot of squares to retreat to so
let me make sure let me make sure i've
got the accurate
position on my actual position right now
actually oops i've got the wrong
sorry i apologies i typed in
and so this is the position knight b2
so you were just saying hey wait a
minute this knight looks a little bit
uh over extended so rook d4 so we can't
really go to rook a1 because then just
knight takes c4
right because even with a1 the idea
would be to try to loosen up that
but the c4 problem was hanging in that
variation you mean
at the very start of the variation okay
one and
if we had like something like bishop f1
even this would be worth considering but
now
this is totally bishop bishop b2 is
threatened so black's totally fine so
you start with richie for defending c4
but now
we wonder is rook a1 in the air well not
only is rook a1 in the air there
there's a bevy of threats uh knight e4
knight f6 is the first line that would
definitely get my attention there's so
many checkmating patterns
yeah that we can achieve as soon as we
get on our knight to f6
what's even worse is that when you play
knight e4 you're also threatening
the more subtle just instead of just
mating you're also studying rook a1 and
rook a2 perhaps trapping the knight
exactly so you've got kind of a really
gross threat there because after rook a1
the bishop would be forced to move back
rook a2 would would snag the knight
perhaps
okay so let's just put that what what
jennifer is saying to our
um viewers that one of the
uh threats that garyv has is like hey
wait a minute this night on b2
kind of on a mission suicide mission
may not get back into the game and after
rook a2 is just trapped
in mid-air on the b2 square so black
black would have to
try to do some tactical things with
bishop b4 but then of course we'd have
knight a4
exactly knight a4 yeah so
some seri need to find some tactical
ways to kind of
deal with all these threats like maybe
he can
play bishop before and knight a4
but then you're going to play 1994
knight f6 check but can we survive that
well do keep in mind that when you put
uh
these two pieces on the same rank as the
room
c5 i got a little uh nasty
uh surprise for you there with c5 one of
these pieces
well you could play a5 it's true no then
i won't bother
about it but you you wouldn't bother
with the 96
thing instead yeah i would bother with
the knight f6 so i'm
i'm looking at this move rook d4
i know uh great attacking players like
larry
christensen for one would just be
chomping at the bit
saying hey look
if you want to help me pardon me get my
knight
over here to that f6 square
i'll go for it jack get your king stuck
in the corner over there i'll go
rook here this is one of the problems
with black's pawn
structure is those double pawns when
white played the move bishop takes h6
he's dreaming of the opportunity of
playing rook h6 and rook takes h7 me but
how
how do you increase the pressure if i
just play king to g7 well exactly king
g7 because then i've worked g4
check i i played back to h8 and then
what's new what's your favorite rover
that's right you just you're probably
bring the other bring my friend
my little friend yes exactly so um
one idea you might have as a kind of a
goddakamsky
kind of thing knight h2 knight g4
going after this pawn on h6 so all the
moves that you're considering have one
thing in common
they bring another guy to the attack
right precisely issue
when you're gonna go on attack it's kind
of like having a party you gotta make
sure that every
every one of your pieces gets an invite
that's such a peaceful way to think of
it when you're just trying to slash
somebody open right
right it's a party it's a party that
won't hurt
exactly at least not for a long time i
may have the attack successful
so i see great compensation here
great competition
ownership is going to have to find some
wonderful defensive
moves on the other hand that's what
chess is all about if you find all of
those moves
that extra a-pawn could very well carry
the day
for ownership because it is passed if
there are defensive moves he's usually
up to
the task of finding him no kidding no
kidding he
is really remarkable and we have a pawn
capture
in the kamsky line tournament game c2
has fallen
so let's see what uh kansas city's
attacking ideas are
okay it looks like the pods are just
stuff falling down like dominoes so
is there some some checkmating ideas how
do we get here okay
so when we have left it uh the bishops
had just been traded rook c6
queen came to d2 queen came to c5
knight dropped back to f3 again god is
kind of basically saying
um i'm going to play a move like queen
f4 and to try to win this pawn
on d4 also with rook c1 by the way
alex lenderman captured the pawn on c2
breaking through
on the queen side and i would anticipate
that queen takes b4 was got his idea
and by the way it looks to me like
these pawns on d4 and a3 are
really vulnerable i spoke badly about
this bishop
on 8th a6 a moment ago but the problem
from
black's point of view is he can't take
right away because of this night fork
queen takes and white would win the
exchange and the game
so knight comes once the knight comes to
d4
that's just going to be terrific
actually for
ghada that's right so instead of bishop
takes d3 we would have to consider the
other capture queen takes d3
okay after queen takes d3
um pause here for a moment because new
possibilities are open
i'm always i'm always on
sorry to say it i'm a nice
quiet positional kind of guy but in
truth i'm always
looking for an opportunity to sack my
opponent's king
and that move queen e7 i
i don't think i could resist playing a
move like queen e7
even though i could go after this pawn
on d4 with the mundane rook d1
that move queen e7 really does
capture my attention the idea is of
first of all is what are you going to do
with your knight you can't move your
knight because again
it's a checkmate to go uh with this pawn
on h7
h6 i said you have to actually protect
them you have to protect the knight but
that's not
uh so easy either for black there's not
how many moves that do it
yeah i see one i see rook c1
and guess what remember when when
black's dream was to
have firm control of the c file well
guess what it's going to be
white's turn to have control of z i see
this position
as going splendidly in white's favor
and i don't think lenderman is going to
last
in this position so he's got this looks
kind of complete
yeah he's got he's facing a real
challenge here
to come up with a move that will keep
his position in
well maybe he's going to try to trade
queens or at least stop queen to e7 so
instead of capturing on d3
all right we're treating the queen to c5
probably
yeah probably best and
then you've got an issue there that
after for example queen takes d4 just
keeping the pawn and saying well i'm a
pawn up dude
queen takes d4 knight d4 that little
tickle on the rook
but what about rook c3 now now we're now
we're attacking d3 twice
and can you defend it well first of all
the trade of
of um queens i think is a
a very important plus uh i no longer
have
uh checkmate on the go but here i still
like white's position for example after
bishop diva
this knight on d4 is a really annoying
animal and after f2 f4 i like kamsky's
position
i don't say he's winning but it's just
very pleasant for the first player well
also after queen c5 he's not forced to
play queen takes d4 but he could also
just play queen d2
and keep the a lot of the problems that
were there before now rook c1 is in the
air
and it still looks uh quite attractive
for white i might go for this instead
keep queens on the board and a lot of
the trumps that you mentioned earlier
rather than
simplify and give lendermen a chance to
get back into the game
unless uh unless queen c3 is good here
well queen c3 yeah i i actually think he
you're going to end up having to play a
queen c3 so that
at least in this position you don't well
you don't you can't play well just a
second because
there's still the good works you want
move exactly and there's a
very powerful knight takes d4 move
here you black doesn't have time to play
d4 d3 himself
but the pawn on d4 is eliminated
so so after queen c3 queen f4 doesn't
look like it was a very
well you could take you can't take on d3
either because after queen f4
i'm protecting the knight on f3 so i'd
have
well i'm still liking white's position
very much i i think gotta is very much
still
in the driver's seat in this game
i do see that this pawn on d4 is a
perpetual weakness
and black has not yet sold um
his problems right yeah i was also
looking tactically
at queen f4 queen v3 whether bishop f1
is
is any good but uh but uh anyway
uh this whole this will be interesting
to watch oh for sure
i guess you you can get queen of five
and
yeah but i do see uh and godda kamsky if
he wins this game
he switches places with lenderman uh in
the lead
in uh this uh pivotal round
wow and we cross the halfway point yeah
definitely in the women's championship
we've got that game between crush and
melakina
that we predict is going to get pretty
nasty maurice how's it going
well it looks as though irena is just in
huge
trouble she has played a few moves that
did not make any sense
but really i couldn't find anything good
for her it just looks like her position
is going slowly but surely downhill
and the more i analyze trying to defend
with houdini the worse it looks
she played the move bishop to e2 here
guarding against any potential
sacrifices
on f3 but now melahina played the move
knight to d5 remember this knight was so
terrible over here and was pushed around
the board now it's centralized
and the lines start to get crazy for
for white simple moves like bishop to d3
might just run into
a sacrifice like rook takes f3 anyway
i mean you can't play queen takes
because of this check
and there's no place to hide your king
because there's going to be a discover
check of one form or another that's
gonna pick your queen off the board
i give you an example like king to f1
knight to e3
check and after takes there goes the
queen
so in this position after after
bishop to after rook to f5 she played
the defensive move bishop to e2 knight
to d5
and now she played the move rook to c1 a
move that
does not really catch houdini's fancy
and now houdini's saying
almost any move is better for black
black is for choice
in this position there are a number of
moves to play you could play for simple
stuff like putting a knight on f4
and getting this bishop from from white
you could play check on this side but
the line that's the most testing
that arena will have to worry about if
it drops on the board is this move
h5 looking to just play h4
and win a bishop what do you do now if
you push your pawn which looks like
really the only thing to do is start
maybe push one or two you weaken this
side considerably
and there are different options here
it's you could play for h4
to to strengthen the grip on this side
now you can play for knight f4 bishop g5
the position is in need of containment
for white it's clear that though she's
up a pawn
this formation does not breed any
confidence
whatsoever and it's black for choice
literally
almost any black move almost any black
move
is good that's how bad it is right now
it's not a good position
for the reigning champion to find
herself in
she